a cientos de mujeres se aglomeraron en
las inmediaciones del congreso argentino
durante la tarde de este miércoles
portando pañuelos verdes o prendas de
vestir de ese color que caracteriza la
lucha por el aborto legal de argentina
ofrecieron su respaldo al presidente
alberto fernández quien envió el
parlamento un proyecto de ley para
despenalizar la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo la iniciativa del ejecutivo
abrió nuevamente un debate que parecía
cerrado en 2018
finalmente para nosotros además de un
reconocimiento
por años diversos movimientos en
argentina han exigido un mayor derecho
de las mujeres a decidir sobre sus
cuerpos hace exactamente dos años una
iniciativa similar a la propuesta por
fernández pasó la aprobación de los
diputados pero fue rechazada por el
senado
todo bien
de la secretaria legal y técnica de la
nación revelan que en el país se
producen entre 370.000 y 520 mil
interrupciones voluntarias del embarazo
por año para el presidente fernández los
derechos reproductivos también son un
problema de salud pública